>>[Presenter named Boris] Welcome, everybody,
to another Authors at Google talk.
Today, we have with us author Richard Martin,
whose new book just came out.
Let me actually-- [pause] This is the book,
SuperFuel: Thorium, the Green Energy Source
for the Future.
We had several speakers at Google already
talk about thorium, but Richard is the author
who actually brought the whole thorium discussion
to the forefront here with his piece in the
Wired magazine.
He's been a science writer for many years.
He's also an award-winning journalist and
he is the editorial director of Pike Research,
a leading clean energy firm.
He lives in Boulder, Colorado, with his wife
and son.
I just want to introduce to those of you who
haven't heard about thorium much.
I think it's-- As you probably know, over
60% of our energy today comes from coal, gas,
and petroleum.
This is causing a lot of issues.
You've all heard Al Gore's talks.
I would like to plug in for those of you who
really think that there's still a debate going
on on CO2 or something to go and look back
at Inez Fung's talk on climate modeling, which
is also available on Youtube, and which should
convince you that it's really serious stuff.
Thorium as the energy source is an important
gap-step if you're trying to deal with this
issue seriously.
Please welcome Richard Martin to share with
us.
[applause]
>>[Richard Martin] Thank you Boris, and thank
you to everyone for coming.
It's been interesting.
The Wired story on thorium came out at the
end of 2009, so I've been reporting on this
for about 3 years.
It's really been interesting to see this movement
that really started out with a committed band
of outsiders really grow to a worldwide wave
in which there are actual businesses raising
actual money and hopefully building and licensing
actual reactors.
I am going to give you the final chapter of
the book today, and really start from the
60,000 foot view and zoom in and talk about
what needs to happen to actually make thorium
power reality.
We're going to actually start with the Roman
Empire.
[pause] In 416 AD, a Roman bureaucrat named
Rutilius Namatianus set out from the imperial
capital to his homeland of Gaul.
He wrote a verse, a long poem, a verse account
of his journey, which was called De Reditu
Suo, which means "Of His Return."
It gives a very vivid portrait of the empire
in decline.
It was several decades before the traditional
fall of the Roman Empire.
The most remarkable thing about Rutilius'
return was that he traveled by boat.
The reason that's remarkable, of course, is
that the Roman Empire was famed for its vast
network of roads that really connected most
of the known world.
Here's what he said: "I have chosen the sea
since roads by land, if on the level, are
flooded by rivers, if on higher ground, are
beset with rocks.
Since Tuscany and since the Aurelian highway,
after suffering the outrages of Goths with
fire or sword can no longer control forest
with homestead or river with bridge, it's
better to entrust my sails to the wayward
sea."
In other words, by the time of Rutilius' return,
the empire's decline was already inescapable.
Roads had decayed, aqueducts had collapsed,
cities lay in ruin, harbors had silted.
So why did the Roman Empire fall?
Someone has counted up the number of theories
to explain the fall of Rome.
They counted 210 theories, from poisoning
with wine goblets made of lead to moral decay
to the hiring of mercenaries to replace the
traditional Roman legionaries.
The one that really interests me here was
outlined by Joseph Tainter in a 1990 book
called The Collapse of Complex Societies.
[phone rings in background] It has to do with
what's called "energy return on investment."
So put simply, the energy required to maintain
the Roman lifestyle, all those monuments,
games and spectacles, feasts, and central
heated bathhouses, became more and more costly
as centuries passed.
Fertile cropland was depleted, and landscapes
were deforested.
The empire had to import grain from farther
and farther afield.
Even as the imperial infrastructure, roads,
bridges, aqueducts, grain mills, fortifications,
and so on, fell into disrepair.
Remote borders became harder to defend.
The army, the source of Rome's might for a
millennium, went underfed and unmotivated.
By the end, Rome was easy pickings for the
barbarian hoards.
Here's-- Tainter actually in an interview--
The great problem Rome faced was when they
would have to incur very high cost just to
maintain the status quo.
They had to invest very high amounts in solving
problems that didn't yield a positive return,
but instead simply allowed them to maintain
what they already had.
I would argue that that's a very succinct
description of the predicament we find ourselves
in today.
Essentially, imperial Rome fell because it
failed to diversify its energy sources.
Notably, an innovative technology existed
to do just that.
Rome was the first civilization to develop
all the necessary components for the world's
first steam engine, but it never built one
for practical use.
In the 1st century AD, a man named Hero of
Alexandria, who was a Greek living under Roman
rule, described an aelophile, which was named
for Aeolus, the god of wind, which is now
considered the first device powered by steam.
It was a water-filled cauldron, that's the
big container you see, heated by a fire, obviously,
with a pair of tubes projecting upwards from
its lid.
The tubes supported a metal sphere that spun
on its horizontal axis, with two nozzles or
tip-jets protruding from it and bent in opposite
directions.
Expelled through nozzles, steam generated
thrust that spun the ball.
It was considered a marvel of ingenuity, but
something of a parlor trick.
The Romans never thought to use steam to drive
machines to perform labor.
Why should they, when slave labor was so cheap
and plentiful?
Moving forward in time a bit.
In a great book, The March of Folly, the historian
Barbara Tuchman catalogues a series of critical
turning points at which governments and societies,
trapped in the status quo despite mounting
contrary evidence, failed to leap imaginatively,
to take bold and visionary steps into the
future, and to change the course of events.
Tuchman called it "pursuit of policy contrary
to self-interest."
Some of the points that she described were
the start of World War I, Vietnam and the
US, etc.
I mean the US in Vietnam, etc.
Here's what Tuchman wrote: "Wooden-headedness
consists of assessing a situation in terms
of preconceived, fixed notions while ignoring
or rejecting any contrary signs."
That definition applies perfectly to our current
nuclear power industry, and, I would argue,
the whole power system.
Ignoring the potential for thorium power in
the 1960s and 1970s, which is what we did,
was short-sighted.
To do so now would be folly.
Going back to Rome for a moment, in the 3rd
century AD, the emperor Diocletian staved
off the fall of the empire for a few decades
by oppressing the peasantry, raising taxes
to crushing levels, expanding his stifling
bureaucracy, and building up the army through
the employment of mercenaries.
Diocletian assessed the situation in terms
of his preconceptions, and it worked, for
a while, but it looks mighty foolish 17 centuries
later.
Let's talk about nuclear power for a moment.
Most of you will be familiar with what I'm
about to talk about.
Nuclear power provides about 20% of electricity
in the US and about the same percentage worldwide.
In France, it's much higher.
It's about 80% in France.
By many measures, the nuclear power industry
has been successful.
Despite some very spectacular accidents, which
I'll talk about in a moment, it has a relatively
clean safety record.
Over the last 10 years, what's happened is
the nuclear power industry has gone through
what they call upbraiding, which basically
means running the reactors at higher power
levels than they were conventionally designed
for.
They've relicensed existing power plants beyond
their original design life, which, to me,
doesn't sound like a recipe for sustained
prosperity.
The other thing about nuclear power is that
it's stagnant in terms of innovation.
The nuclear regulatory commission just licensed
the first new nuclear plant in the US in 34
years.
It's a two-reactor plant in Georgia.
It's conventional light water uranium reactors,
which is basically 40 year old technology.
If you think about what happens here and at
your company, what's happened over those 4
decades, it's as if we're all still using
Atari 800 computers from about 1980.
So the nuclear power industry has suffered
from a lack of innovation.
The other thing that's happened is the people
who are running the nuclear power industry
are the same people who brought you Three
Mile Island, because what happened was when
the industry began to really stagnate in the
'80s, people didn't go into it.
They started going elsewhere.
They went to Wall Street, they started going
to Silicon Valley, etc.
So there's a doughnut hole in the middle in
terms of personnel in the industry.
That's starting to change.
A lot of young people are starting to go into
the industry again.
Nuclear engineering departments are starting
to get full again.
But something needs to change to really bring
the industry into the 21st century.
I would argue that it's thorium.
Just briefly on thorium.
I'm going to assume that a lot of you have
heard of thorium power.
As Boris mentioned, Kirk Sorensen has been
here.
He's one of the leaders of the thorium revival
in the US.
Thorium is about 4 times as abundant as uranium.
It's about as common as lead.
I've heard it said that in India, which by
some measures has the largest resources of
thorium in the world, if you scoop up a handful
of sand on a beach in Mumbai, you've got enough
thorium in your hand to power the city for
a year.
That sounds apocryphal to me, but it does
give you a sense of how common it is and what
a dense and efficient source of energy it
is.
The other thing about thorium is that it's
fertile, it's not fissile.
What I mean by that is you can't cram a bunch
of thorium into a small space and create a
critical mass and start a spontaneous chain
reaction.
You have to have an external source of neutrons.
And what happens when you bombard thorium
with neutrons, it goes through a nuclear decay
chain and eventually reaches actually an isotope
of uranium, which is U-233.
The type of uranium that is consumed in nuclear
reactors is actually U-235, which is very
rare in nature.
So that's why you have to enrich natural uranium
up to a certain level of U-235 to create a
substance you can use to run a reactor with.
If you enrich uranium to about 3 to 5% or
maybe 7% U-235, you've got reactor-grade uranium.
If you continue and enrich it to 20%, you've
got weapons-grade uranium.
So that's the drama, the dilemma we see unfolding
in Iran right now.
If you have a civilian nuclear power industry
with centrifuges to enrich uranium, it's relatively
easy to enrich it to weapons-grade.
You don't have to enrich thorium at all.
You can use naturally occurring thorium.
You do need a small igniter fuel to bombard
the thorium, and it transmutes on its own
and becomes U-233, which is in many ways a
better source of energy than U-235.
Finally, the nuclear waste issue, which, as
you know, we've totally failed to solve.
The Obama Administration is in favor of new
nuclear power, but it has essentially killed
the Yucca Mountain storage facility.
Those are irreconcilable positions, and we
don't have a solution for nuclear waste right
now.
So if you use thorium in the right kind of
reactors, which I'm going to describe in a
minute, they're called liquid fluoride thorium
reactors, not only do they produce much, much
less waste, which is much shorter-lived in
terms of the radiotoxicity, you can also consume
or process existing waste from conventional
nuclear reactors and burn it down essentially
into a form that's much easier to store and
much easier to deal with.
I've had people argue against that, but the
fact is, the way to solve the nuclear waste
problem is to build liquid fluoride thorium
reactors, which are known as LFTRs.
There are several other advantages to using
thorium instead of uranium, one of which is
thorium is a distributed resource.
There will never be a Saudi Arabia of thorium.
It's found everywhere.
Everybody has a little, a lot of people have
a lot.
The US has, the latest estimate, although
these estimates are often revised, is that
the US has 440,000 tons of uranium resources
in the ground.
The other thing is we've got a bunch that
has already been produced for the experiments
that went on in the '60s.
It's sitting in the desert in Nevada.
It's enough to power the US for the next 100
years.
The current plan on the part of the DOE is
to downblend that thorium with spent uranium
fuel and bury it, essentially.
That gives you a sense of how crazy our policy
is right now on nuclear power.
Enacting the same policy that hasn't worked
to date only more forcefully is an accurate
description of the nuclear industry's strategy,
its so-called "nuclear Renaissance."
Energy policy is a toxic blend of wooden-headedness,
economic self-interest, scientific ignorance,
theology, and technological inertia.
In particular, the nuclear power industry
suffers from technological lock-in, which
I'm sure is a term that all of you are familiar
with: the tendency of established technologies
to crowd other competing and possibly superior
systems out of the market.
The best known example, of course, is our
friend Microsoft.
Few people would suggest that Windows is the
ideal operating system for a personal computer,
but Bill Gates is a brilliant and ruthless
businessman, and even today, Windows controls
something like 90% of the PC market.
The stagnation of nuclear power technology
has followed similar lines, and it was apparent
a long time ago.
Back in 1990, Robin Cowan, who is a professor
at the University of Strasbourg, wrote, "While
an appropriate decision at the time, it now
seems that light water reactors" --in other
words, conventional uranium-based reactors--
"may have been an unfortunate choice."
One of the most interesting features of this
history is the belief held by many that light
water is not the best technology, either economically
or technically.
I've talked to a lot of people in nuclear
establishment, as I call it, over the last
few years.
Just about every one of them, at some point,
has uttered a version of what I think is a
classic quote.
This came from a guy named Paul Genoa, who's
a spokesman for the Nuclear Energy Institute,
which is the DC based trade association, the
lobbying group for the nuclear power industry.
He was interviewed by the Nashville Tennessean
newspaper in a story about thorium.
Here's what he said.
He said, "You don't just walk away from the
established technology base, the reactor fleet
that we have today, and try the new, shiny
toy, even if the new, shiny toy might work
better."
Think about that for a minute.
Even if it works better.
Let's talk about risk.
In September of 2010, a natural gas pipeline
exploded in San Bruno, California, not far
from here.
It killed 8 people immediately.
35 houses were leveled.
Dozens more were damaged.
It created a crater, 167 feet long, 26 feet
wide, and 39 feet deep.
It was like an asteroid the size of a refrigerator
had gouged the Earth.
When's the last time you saw a headline about
the San Bruno natural gas explosion?
Natural gas is considered a relatively clean
fuel, right?
We have a bunch of it, and it's really cheap
right now.
But that accident was one of a rash of industrial
accidents around fossil fuels that included
the 2006 Sago Mine disaster, which killed
12 people, the collapse of the Kingston Fossil
Plant in Tennessee in 2008, which resulted
in the largest release of coal ash in US history,
and the Upper Big Branch coal mine explosion,
which killed 29 miners in April of 2010.
The most famous, though, was the April 2010
blast that brought down the Deepwater Horizon
offshore oil rig, killing 11 workers and spilling
206 million gallons of crude oil into the
Gulf of Mexico.
Other countries have not been immune.
In July 2010, an oil pipeline exploded at
the Port of Dalian in northeast China, resulting
in the worst oil spill in Chinese history.
Now let's talk about Fukushima Dai-ichi.
I'm going to preface this by saying I am not
dismissing the seriousness of that accident.
But if you step back for a minute and think
about the nuclear accident at the Fukushima
Dai-ichi plant, three people died.
Two were workers trapped in the turbine hall
of reactor 4, which ironically was the only
reactor that contained no fuel at the time
of the earthquake and tsunami.
A third man died at Fukushima Dai-ichi, which
is Dai-ichi's sister plant nearby.
Again, it will take many decades and billions
of dollars to clean up after the Fukushima
nuclear accident.
As you've seen in the headlines recently,
they're now seeing radioactive tuna show up
off the coast of California, which is worrisome.
The damage to the national psyche of Japan,
which is a country, of course, it's the only
country that's had two cities destroyed by
nuclear bombs, and which really has worked
since World War II to harness the power of
nuclear energy for good.
The damage to the national psyche there has
been incalculable.
And of course, Japan's last reactors have
either shut down or are in the process of
shutting down.
But in the context of the wider earthquake
and tsunami, which killed at least 18,000
people, the nuclear accident was a footnote.
In comparison with the series of fossil fuel
disasters that I've just described, it hardly
rates mention.
Arnold Gundersen is a former nuclear power
executive who served as an expert witness
in the investigation of the Three Mile Island
accident.
He's become a loud voice in opposition to
nuclear power.
He called Fukushima the biggest industrial
catastrophe in the history of mankind.
So my point is, that gives you an idea of
how distorted our views of nuclear power and
radioactivity and nuclear accidents really
are.
Fukushima also highlighted our inability to
accurately calculate risk.
From its earliest days, the nuclear power
industry has faced a fundamental dichotomy
around risk.
The chances of a significant accident in any
single nuclear power plant are very, very
low, but the theoretically possible consequences
of a runaway accident are almost unimaginable.
My view is that risk aversion in the nuclear
power industry takes two forms: one is technological,
one is financial.
Apart from a relatively small group of scientists
and engineers who I profile in SuperFuel,
most nuclear technologies today are hemmed
in by an incrementalism that eliminates the
possibility of bold and visionary leaps.
The Blue Ribbon Commission on America's nuclear
future, which was formed by the Obama Administration
soon after Barack Obama took office, has looked
at various pathways forward for nuclear power
in the 21st century, including, on that list
is thorium reactors.
But the chances of getting something licensed
in this country and getting financed and getting
built are slim.
Only the smallest and most predictable next
step is safe enough to pursue.
The perception of danger is too high.
As a result, we're stuck with 1970s technology.
It's like we're driving Ford Fairlanes that
have been suped up to run at higher rpms and
have a new pair of whitewalls on them.
That's our current reactor fleet.
So here's the real risk, and Boris referred
to this.
This is one of many charts.
This basically is various predictions of the
rise in temperature through the end of the
century in degrees Celsius.
This is what scares me.
If you look at the risk of a nuclear power
accident in general, from conventional nuclear
power, much less from thorium reactors, which
are far safer, versus this risk that we're
looking at.
There's no comparison.
We're hastening the onset of disasters, global
climate change, by continuing to burn fossil
fuels.
Just a word about natural gas: I just wrote
part of a cover package for Fortune magazine
about the natural gas boom.
That's a great thing for America.
$2 natural gas is a great thing.
We're actually exporting natural gas from
the Gulf Coast to western Europe because even
with the transport costs, which with natural
gas are pretty high, the price, once you get
it to Brussels or wherever in Europe, it's
still much cheaper.
That's not going to last.
That price imbalance is not going to last.
The natural gas industry is not yet-- the
market is not yet globalized like the oil
industry is.
That's going to change.
Being simply the low-cost provider of cheap
energy is not a pathway to sustain prosperity.
If we continue on our current path, large
coastal cities could be underwater, millions
of acres of agricultural land will have turned
to desert, severe drought will be widespread,
resource wars fought over increasingly scarce
supplies of water and energy will become,
and so on.
But again, we have a perceptual problem.
The prospect of global climate change is abstract
and distant to most Americans.
There have been some polls recently that are
staggering.
Only something like 35% of Americans consider
global climate change a real threat.
They are a lot less terrifying than the tiny,
but real, risk of nuclear accident, which
has been of course amply displayed at Chernobyl
and now at Fukushima.
So we're not good at calculating risk.
Our inability to calculate risk is multiplied
by what Nassim Nicholas Taleb, in his bestseller
The Black Swan, called the "false belief that
our tools can measure uncertainty."
Taleb goes on, "The application of sciences
of uncertainty to real-world problems has
had ridiculous effects."
Of course, he was referring mostly to the
financial markets, where the tendency to overlook
outlying and unlikely possibilities, which
he terms "black swan events," help leads to
the economic crash of 2008.
Taleb argues that it's human nature, when
you're planning for the future, not to account
for highly improbable yet catastrophic disruptions:
the explosion of the space shuttle Columbia,
for instance, the assassination of JFK, or
the Fukushima tsunami, because our forecasting
models are ruled by the bell curve of predictability.
Nuclear power has the opposite problem.
Nuclear power is one of the few areas of modern
life where the merest possibility of a black
swan event, another Chernobyl or another Fukushima,
has trapped the entire industry in a net of
anxiety and caution.
Nuclear power, as I said, has a reverse black
swan problem.
To me, it's similar to the so-called war on
terror.
Since 2001, fears of another terror attack
have poisoned American life and cost America
billions of dollars in ways both visible,
in terms of long lines at security at airports,
for instance, and invisible, including the
difficulty of foreigners to come work for
companies like Google because of visa issues.
Despite the comparatively clean safety record
of the nuclear power industry, the potential
of nuclear power, at least in the US, has
been stifled by risks that are almost too
small to measure.
There's obvious counterexamples in US history.
Two of the most obvious are the Manhattan
Project and the Apollo program to land men
on the moon.
The similarities in those: both depended on
technologies that did not exist when the programs
began.
Both called forth entire new industries based
around those technologies, industries that
had no obvious everyday benefits or profit
potential before they arose, and both involved
high opportunity costs, in that they demanded
resources, financial and intellectual, that
could have been devoted to other more easily
attainable objectives.
And of course, I'm sure you're all-- The thought
bubble that is right now is the internet above
your heads.
A very similar situation.
No one realized what would grow up when DARPA
first started connecting computers.
So what's changed?
Why are we incapable of summoning the will,
the confidence, and the unity to produce similar
achievements against a threat that is every
bit as existential as World War II or the
Cold War?
The first and most obvious is the political
system.
I probably don't need to tell any of you how
impossible it is to get the US Congress to
take action on any critical matter of long-term
national security and prosperity.
The other change, however, is the financial
system.
Current levels of government debt make a quote
"new Manhattan Project for energy" unquote
impossible.
At the same time, the evolution of the private
sector financial system, particularly private
equity in the stock market, favors quick returns
over long-term investment.
Clear exit strategies over building new industries.
Consumer focused technologies, mobile phones
and applications, social media, new forms
of entertainment, over large and complex infrastructure
projects.
And again, we've seen a pretty clear example
of that in what's happened with the Facebook
IPO over the last several weeks.
In other words, we can't do it because we've
never done it before, and even if we could
do it, the public will never support it.
But again, there's a counterexample.
The rebirth of the US auto industry, based
on 80 billion dollars in federal loans and
investments, allowed GM and Chrysler to exit
bankruptcy and begin paying back the loans
from the US Treasury by the end of 2009.
In the first quarter of last year, both GM
and Chrysler, along with Ford, posted quarterly
net profits and were achieving their first
sustained net sales gain since the 1980s.
The automakers turnaround helped stabilize
the overall US economy and helped the manufacturing
sector add almost a quarter million jobs between
the end of 2009 and mid 2011.
This was industrial policy, although nobody
wants to call it that because that, for years,
has been a term of contempt in Washington.
And it worked.
So what are the lessons for the energy industry
from the auto bailout?
First of all, there has to be a sense of crisis.
Two major US automakers failing in the midst
of a global financial crisis constituted a
crisis in most people's minds.
But the majority of Americans I mentioned
earlier don't see the prospect of global warming
as a crisis.
Number two is that long-term social and national
economic goals, not just narrow shareholder
value, must guide the transformation.
Having a strong and competitive auto industry
is clearly seen as a key national interest.
Having a strong competitive and innovative
energy industry is also a key national interest.
New technology must be the basis of the transformation,
with a few notable exceptions.
The nuclear power industry's plans for the
next generation of reactors can be summarized
as the same, only more so.
Any nationwide energy strategy should promote
and require the rapid development and deployment
of new forms of nuclear power, especially
liquid-fueled thorium reactors.
Government support is necessary, but must
be limited and conditional.
The big auto makers wound up repaying the
billions invested in them by the US government,
but that funding came at a price.
They had to replace top executives and invest
in new technology, come up with new labor
relations and new production systems.
Everyone had to give up something.
The transformation must draw on America's
innate competitive advantages.
The US has the top engineering schools in
the world, a vibrant alternative energy investment
market, a pervasive though aging power grid,
and increasingly open and deregulated energy
markets.
Also, large numbers of investors, scientists,
and entrepreneurs who view the energy crisis
as the signal challenge of the 21st century.
Plus, we invented thorium-fueled reactors.
So how much would all this cost?
These are a couple of graphs about trying
to figure out what the real cost of energy
is.
Nuclear power is in the middle of both these
graphs.
There have been various attempts to calculate
the overall cost of electricity from a thorium-fueled
nuclear plant.
That depends on many factors that are pretty
hard to calculate right now, including the
cost of capital, length of time licensing
operating costs such as labor and overtime,
operating efficiency, and so on.
But various thorium supporters have calculated
that the overnight cost for a LFTR plant,
the overnight costs are the costs to build
and start up a plant excluding interest and
other collateral costs, and they came up with
a range of around $2200 per kilowatt of capacity,
plus or minus 30% or so.
So a 1 megawatt prototype plant would cost
2.2 million in overnight costs.
And a commercial 1000 megawatt plant would
cost around 2.2 billion.
Other estimators have come up with lower costs
around $1400 per kilowatt.
I would argue that what we're going to see
is once LFTRs, liquid-fueled thorium reactors,
start to be built, the cost of the technology
is going to come down fairly rapidly.
But you have to factor in the social costs
as well.
Liquid-fueled thorium reactors are carbon
free.
Their contribution to nuclear proliferation
risk is essentially zero.
They not only eliminate the cost of long-term
storage of new radioactive waste, but also
can process existing waste from conventional
plants, making it very much easier to store.
They'll jump start a new era of energy technology
innovation that will benefit companies in
the nation in ways that are impossible to
quantify right now.
Considering those benefits, there's no question
that thorium power offers the most economical
avenue to bring on line massive amounts of
new generating capacity without adding to
current levels of carbon emissions.
So how much do we need?
In 2010, the US consumed about 3.8 million
gigawatt hours of electricity.
Coal accounted for 44% of that, nuclear, as
I've said, for about 20%.
Total US electricity generating capacity is
about a thousand gigawatts.
Under an optimistic scenario for renewable
energy production from wind, solar, biomass,
geothermal, and so on, let's say that to reduce
carbon emissions enough to stave off catastrophic
climate change, by 2050 we must increase the
portion of our electricity generated by power
to half.
One half of a thousand gigawatts is 500 gigawatts
or 500,000 megawatts of capacity.
That's a lot.
What are the goals?
Electricity demand, of course, will grow in
the next four decades.
Some people think as much as 50-60%, but I'm
being optimistic, so let's say that improved
conservation technology and changing consumer
habits will limit the increase in demand.
We must build enough new nuclear power plants
to generate 500 gigawatts, or 500,000 megawatts
of clean, low cost power by 2050.
That's the equivalent of about 500 1000 megawatt
nuclear plants, or, if we built smaller modular
liquid-fueled thorium reactors that can be
mass produced in a factory, that would be
about 2000 250 megawatt reactors.
That means between 2050 and 2050, over 30
years, we need to build about 17 new nuclear
plants a year.
Let's be ambitious and call it 20 new thousand
megawatt thorium plants a year, or 80 250
megawatt LFTRs, for a total of 600 plants.
That's a hugely ambitious goal.
But again, how much will it really cost?
One of the beauties of LFTRs is that they
can be mass produced.
Small modular reactors can be built in 250
megawatt sizes and assembled into larger plants.
By comparison, Boeing builds about one 200
million dollar jet a day.
A modern airliner has many more moving parts
and greater overall complexity than a liquid-fueled
thorium reactor.
If we build, say, four plants for manufacturing
LFTRs, with each plant producing five reactors
a year, that would just about do the trick.
Think about the jobs and the spillover economic
benefits for the states in which those plants
are located.
Technology advances, again, will bring the
costs down rapidly after commercialization,
potentially to the cost of a new jet.
Let's call it one billion dollars per thousand
megawatt plant.
Cost of building 600,000 megawatt LFTRs or
600,000 megawatt plants or 2400 250 megawatt
machines would come to 600 billion.
Add 15% for startup costs and financing, round
up, you've got 700 billion dollars.
That's a lot of money.
But let's put it in perspective.
In 2010, the budget for the US Department
of Defense was about 685 billion dollars,
which, by the way, is almost as much as every
other country in the world combined spends
on their military.
In other words, for about what we spend in
one year on defense, we can build a thorium-based
carbon free energy economy that can last a
millennium.
Many people will, and frankly already have,
scoffed at this program, calling it unrealistic,
too expensive, too risky.
Again, we can't do it because we've never
done it before.
But you have to consider the costs, direct
and indirect, of building any other type of
thousand megawatt power plant, whether it's
coal, conventional nuclear, solar, natural
gas, or of doing nothing and allowing climate
change to run rampant by mid century.
Building a couple dozen LFTRs a year starts
to sound like a bargain.
It's important to remember the obstacles to
creating a thorium power economy in the next
40 years are not technological or economic,
they are political and commercial, Ultimately,
the thorium revival is about the choices we
make as a society.
If we don't do it, it will be because we chose
not to, not because it was impossible.
Thanks very much.
[applause]
>>[Richard Martin] So we have some time for
questions.
>>[Boris] Yes, we have some time for questions.
If you have a question, please raise your
hand.
I'll give you the mike.
>>[audience member #1] So Energy Secretary
Chu, and I believe somebody asked him about
thorium plants.
I think, if I recall correctly, his response
was that the technology wasn't there, like
the liquid fluoride thorium salts are very
caustic and would just eat through the piping
or whatever.
What can you tell us about that?
>>[Richard Martin] What I can tell you about
it is that we've already done it.
What this presentation doesn't cover, but
is covered in three chapters in SuperFuel,
is that in the 1960s at Oak Ridge National
Laboratory, we ran what was called the molten
salt reactor experiment under Alvin Weinberg,
who was the director of Oak Ridge at the time.
I've actually gone to Oak Ridge and I've looked
at Weinberg's papers, which,-- And then again,
this will give you an idea of how we've neglected
our history around nuclear power.
his papers are stored at the Oak Ridge Children's
Museum in a walk-in closet.
You walk in and there's literally filing cabinets
stacked to the ceiling, and nobody has gone
through them, catalogued them, indexed them.
Anyway, the molten salt reactor experiment
ran from about '59 to '73.
It was successful.
They actually did not run it on thorium.
They ran it first on conventional uranium
U-235, and then they started introducing U-233.
But they used molten salt liquid fluoride,
which is the substance that Secretary Chu
was talking about.
There was a report at the end of that experiment,
which basically said-- and it had a cover
letter in which the atomic energy commission
said, "Congratulations, your experiment was
a tremendous success, and now we're shutting
it down."
What happened was instead of pursuing liquid-fueled
thorium reactors, we pursued fast metal breeder
reactors.
That was the Clinch River Project, which some
of you may recall.
I've actually been to the site that was supposed--
where the Clinch River Fast Breeder was supposed
to be built.
I hopped a fence and trespassed on federal
property, walked out to the river.
It's an empty field.
We poured 8 billion dollars down the rat hole
of fast breeder reactors, and we didn't turn
a spade.
So when people say it hasn't been proven,
well, again, there's lots of things that haven't
been proven that we go ahead and build and
we figure it out on the way.
Material science is an important component.
The thing about LFTRs is they're going to
run not for 20 or 30 or 40 years, they're
going to run for 100 years.
One of the remaining technological hurdles
is to come up with the piping, essentially
the plumbing, that will stand up for that
long.
But to say that we haven't developed this
technology is just wrong.
Just a side note on Secretary Chu, people
in the thorium movement have combed his public
utterances looking for the word "thorium",
and the fact is he's in a constrained, politically
appointed post, so I'm not going to presume
to know what's really on his mind but I do
know he's in favor of advanced nuclear and
I do know that thorium-- Everything else is
an incremental step on what we've already
done, and it uses uranium.
Thorium power is the only truly innovative
form of nuclear power technology that's available
to us today.
Secretary Chu is in a position where he's
not about to outrage the entire existing nuclear
power establishment by saying, "We need to
build thorium power reactors."
So I find it hard to believe that he really
believes a statement like that that really
ignores
the history.
[pause] Yes.
[pause]
>>[audience member #2] So you talk a little
about-- a fair amount about the US Congress
and the inability to get stuff done.
But what about China and other countries that
are maybe less constrained by history?
>>[Richard Martin] Thank you for asking.
In 2010, I was the first reporter in the West
to break the story that China is pursuing
a liquid-fueled thorium reactor.
They have committed money to it.
It's a state-sponsored program.
So they're moving forward.
India has a program that's actually been in
place for a few decades.
They call it the "Three Stage Program" to
build dozens of new reactors and convert them
over time in three stages, as you might guess,
to thorium reactors.
But those are solid fuel reactors, and there's
a lot of problems with that.
The basic thing about putting solid thorium
fuel into a more or less conventional reactor,
I compare to putting biofuel in a Hummer.
It might be a little bit better, but you don't
really capture the true advantages of thorium
power.
So India and China are moving forward.
And one other answer to that question: I did
a story for Fortune last year on the rare
earths market.
Rare earths, as I'm sure everyone knows, are
the lanthanide elements, which are used in
a variety of high tech applications, including
smartphone displays, including missile guidance
systems, including electric vehicles.
Unsurprisingly, the US used to be the world's
leading source of rare earths.
Today, China controls 98% of that market.
When you find rare earths, you almost always
find thorium.
So there's these huge mines in western China
where they're producing rare earths, for export
mostly, and thorium is produced as a byproduct.
Reports out of China are that they are stockpiling
that thorium.
Meanwhile, a company called Molycorp is restarting
the Mountain Pass mine, which is on the border
between California and Nevada, it's outside
Las Vegas, which once was the biggest rare
earth mine in the world.
They're putting a few billion dollars into
restarting production at Mountain Pass.
I was there last fall, and I said, "What are
you going to do with the thorium?"
They're going to treat it as radioactive waste
and bury it in concrete.
The executive said, "If there were a market
for this stuff, we'd love to sell it.
But there isn't, and regulations require us
to treat it as radioactive waste."
So China is stockpiling the stuff and planning
on building LFTRs, and we are getting rid
of it.
That's what's happening.
And just one more word on that.
A lot of people in the thorium movement present
it as this apocalypse for the US.
If we don't build thorium reactors and we
let China lead the way in this technology
that we originally developed, we're never
going to catch up.
It's going to be the Roman empire all over
again.
I'm not quite that apocalyptic about it.
There are many things that the US still produces
that other countries want to buy.
But it is true that it would be crazy for
us to give up the technology that we developed
back in the 1960s to another country.
But the thing is, speaking as an internationalist,
it would be a great thing if China built thorium-based
reactors instead of, for instance, coal plants,
because, if you want to do something about
global warming, basically what-- the whole
rest of the world doesn't matter unless we
control it in China.
Speaking as a citizen of the globe, it would
be wonderful if China pursued this technology.
[pause] Yes, sir.
[pause]
>>[audience member #3] As you noted that basically,
the global warming and stuff like that is
not going to convince the public, at least
in the near future.
So why can't the alternative arguments, like
basically the limited resources of the fossil
fuel or the rising cost of that can be used
instead?
>>[Richard Martin] Well, here's one problem
with the argument over limited resources of
fossil fuels.
Let's call it the "peak oil argument" for
short.
We keep finding more.
Specifically, we keep finding more natural
gas through hydraulic fracturing.
And again, I'm not going to say that that's
a terrible thing.
That's a good thing for the US.
I'd rather build natural gas plants than coal
plants.
There's a really interesting talk by Nathan
Myhrvold, former CTO of Microsoft, it's on
Youtube now, in which he talked about the
natural gas boom.
He said, "Look if you think that this is going
to A. provide quote energy independence unquote,
which is an illusion anyway, and B. solve
global climate change, you're wrong."
Natural gas, in combination with nuclear power,
I call it NP plus NG.
If we can build natural gas plants and bring
thorium-based nuclear power online at the
same time, that's a way out of the predicament.
But to answer your question, the fact is,
I'm not sure what the argument is.
Congress-- There have been several bipartisan
bills introduced in Congress to fund R&D for
thorium, and they've never gotten out of committee.
There are friends of mine in the thorium movement
who are lobbying hard to get something done.
Unfortunately, my view on that is that they're
going to grow old waiting for Congress to
do something.
I do think that, in combination with watching
China forge ahead in this technology and the
prospect of losing another technology to the
booming economies of East Asia, combining
that with the prospect of global climate change
does have a chance of convincing some of our
political leaders and then even convincing
some of the public.
Hopefully, the book and other efforts like
it will gradually educate the public.
I think one of the things that have happened,
is what I talked about in the presentation,
is overcoming this knee jerk response to nuclear
power.
It's been interesting to watch the environmental
movement split as they realize the real danger
is climate change, and we need to change our
automatic response to any form of nuclear
power.
You can just watch that split happening.
So what is going to convince people and politicians?
I'm not sure.
But I do think this rising tide that I just
described has a chance of doing it.
[pause] Yes.
[pause]
>>[audience member #4] I was wondering what
percent of the US's energy needs you envision
thorium will satisfy.
This is a two part question.
Once that percent gets achieved, what do you
think the price of energy would be compared
to what it is right now?
>>[Richard Martin] [clears throat] Let's talk
about price first.
The thing about nuclear power is all the costs
are upfront.
It's all cap ex.
Once you've got it-- Even uranium right now
is cheap and plentiful, and there's plenty
of people who, including me, who argue that's
not going to last.
But once you've got a nuclear power plant,
it's very cheap to run.
Somebody told me that the cost of fuel in
a nuclear power plant is less than what they
pay the security guards.
So the challenge is the upfront financing.
This slide, I went back to this just to answer
the first part of that question, which is
the program that I've outlined is to supply
half of our electricity capacity by 2050.
In other words, about 500 gigawatts.
That's huge.
I don't want to underestimate that at all.
Building 600 nuclear plants between 2020 and
2050 seems impossible.
But again, if we can shift our thinking and
shift the process around building and deploying
these plants, it's technologically achievable.
So that's what I'm looking at: basically half
of our energy demand supplied by thorium-based
nuclear power by 2050.
And I just want to stress I am all in favor
of renewables, but they're just not going
to do the trick in the next 30 to 50 years.
The price of solar power is declining rapidly,
and that's a great thing, but it's still the
percentage of pure renewable power right now
of our overall demand is in the low single
digits, and it's not going to change significantly
in my lifetime, frankly.
So we do need nuclear power.
I believe that we can get to 50% by 2050.
Again, the cost is high, but in perspective,
compared to what we spend on defense and what
we would have to spend on other forms of power
generation, it's a bargain.
[pause]
>>[Boris:]Well, thank you.
>>[Richard Martin:]Thanks very much.
Thanks for having me.
[applause]